scp-507 otherwise known as The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper is an anomaly with a
rare condition don't worry though it's
not contagious we think no this
otherwise seemingly ordinary fellow
possesses a rather unpredictable
anomalous trait he can travel to other
dimensions that sounds great in theory
right who Among Us wouldn't want to
visit alternate universes and see worlds
beyond our wildest imaginations well the
problem is that scp-507 can't actually
control this ability it's not something
he can do on a whim or by thinking about
it instead he is relocated to other
universes seemingly at random which can
prove pretty intrusive during an average
day in the life of
scp-507 6am it was still early far too
early for scp-507 to be awake but even
while he slept the foundation was making
sure they had the necessary measures in
place to keep him comfortably can
contained or at least until he next
disappeared your assignment officer
Dalton the security Chief said boredly
sliding a file across the desk you want
me to be the Handler for this reluctant
Dimension Hopper Dalton replied after
she had skimmed through the file in
front of her special containment
procedures for scp-507 clearly dictate
that an agent must be present with the
anomaly whenever he leaves his private
quarters the chief answered with acai
having barely sipped his morning coffee
just keep an eye on him do what he asks
as long as the requests don't violate
internal security Sir with respect
Dalton cleared her throat this feels
like a waste of my talents I'm as combat
proficient and well trained as all other
security operatives why do you want me
playing daycare for someone whose own
files refer to him as quote sporting no
outstanding characteristics what you
thought we'd hire you and immediately
put you in the pen with 682 the security
chief soft don't look a gift horse in
the mouth officer this posting is a
blessing believe me I've given agents
just as competent as you tougher posts
and the number of them who died on the
job well let's just say it makes it
easier being up this early in the day
but sir I could be doing more trust me
start small you'll have your hands full
with 507 it may not seem like much but
he's slippery the chief said you mean
he'll attempt to escape Dalton asked the
facility's head of security didn't give
an answer instead he dismissed the
officer to her posting making her way
through the corridors towards 507's
containment cell officer Dalton studied
her briefing reading it through multiple
times so she understood her assignment
she was expecting her charge to be
unruly attempting Escape at any
opportunity what she had overlooked in
her haste was that scp-507 wasn't
intentionally using his Dimension
hopping powers to escape in fact he
couldn't help it 8 AM eventually growing
tired of waiting outside the entrance to
The Reluctant Dimension Hopper's
quarters officer Dalton began repeatedly
banging her fist against the door
scp-507 wake yourself up she yelled
impatiently there came the sound of
tired groaning from the other side of
the door followed by something
person-sized falling over in a daze
getting to its feet the source of the
noise shuffled closer and opened the
door all while Dalton kept knocking
that's very loud you know
hmm
scp-507 ground eyes half littered
practically still asleep I'm your new
Handler the officer announced plainly
good for you
hmm the dimension Hopper yawned I'm
tired of going back to sleep like hell
you are Dalton snaps striding into the
room I've been waiting outside for two
hours look at Miss
scp-507 side I get the foundation has to
keep an eye on me in case I
you know he made a gesture with his
hands jazzly shaking them you get the
picture he continued but I'm normally in
bed for the first half of the day first
of all Dalton replied sternly I'm an
officer in the foundation as such you'll
refer to me as officer Dalton or ma'am
is that clear she didn't give 507 a
chance to answer secondly make no
mistake I'm not your babysitter I'm here
to ensure the foundation's continued
security not yours and if one of your
Escape attempts poses a threat to this
organization then I am authorized to
carry out a termination order in short
don't screw around with me
scp-507 looks sheepish like a school
child who'd just been told off by the
principal so am I right in thinking you
like to go by nicknames what do I call
you he paused for a second a cheeky
smile crawling across his face as he
figured out a way he could slightly mess
with the no-nonsense officer you can
call me grab knock the Destroyer SCP 507
replied officer Dalton rolled her eyes
this was clearly going to be a long day
10 am sure enough the newly appointed
Handler's first cause for concern came
when scp-507 suddenly blinked out of
existence while brushing his teeth she'd
urged him to go get himself ready and
freshened up and no sooner had grab
knock stepped into the bathroom he
disappeared his toothbrush clattering
into the sink officer Dalton stared in
disbelief at the spot where he had just
been bowled over by how Brazen and how
quickly the anomalous interdimensional
traveler had tried to give her the slip
immediately Dalton went to raise the
alarm only to be ineffectively reassured
by her superiors this kind of thing
happens all the time and all he'll
reappear soon just keep sweeping the
facility until he shows up where all she
was met with and they did little to
quell Dalton's frustration eventually
scp-507 reappeared wandering around one
of the corridors of the foundation
facility and whining about a headache
that usually accompanied his dimensional
displacement what the hell are you
playing at Vanishing like that Dalton
barked I need to eat something grab
knock groaned ignoring her question I
displaced before breakfast it always
makes me nauseous when it's on an empty
stomach that's your primary concern
right now the officer's side well yeah
scp-507 trucked there was no food in
that other dimension at least none that
I could find begrudgingly pushing aside
her frustration Dalton escorted grab
knock to the foundation mess hall what
else was there as cp507 she asked
breaking the silence as he ate quietly
we'll have to file a report about where
you went not answering to that he
chuckled you've got to use the nickname
seriously Dalton replied okay fine what
else was in that Universe RAB knock the
whole thing grab knock the Destroyer she
added through gritted teeth not a lot
honestly the dimension Hopper Shrugged
so some universes are just like that
this one just had a big salt plane and
nothing else you mean like a desert
Dalton probed no assault plane grab
knock corrected her you know like a
glass salt shaker you have that a fancy
dinner table except with wings and what
was in the salt plane she asked confused
I think it was white pepper
scp-507 answered sarcastically 12 p.m
after he finished his meal scp-507
seemed to be feeling better and
requested to be taken back to his
quarters to use his computer he'd been
granted one by the foundation with
limited internet access and a strict
limit on what he could access and upload
however it was while escorting him back
that officer Dalton realized her charge
had once again relocated while her back
was turned Dalton once again proceeded
to Traverse the facility's corridors
checking in with other security staff
and telling her fellow Personnel to keep
her posted if SCP 507 reappears
meanwhile unbeknownst to her The
Reluctant Dimension Hopper had found
himself in a particularly unique
situation arriving in a new alternate
universe
scp-507 was greeted by familiar
headaches standing in a spot that
mirrored the foundation site he had been
in a moment before in fact most of the
details about this universe were almost
identical to the one he had just left
apart from all the dinosaurs it quickly
became apparent at the site of a
Velociraptor wearing a lab coat that
this was a reality where the meteor that
wiped out early life on Earth had never
actually hit as a result the reptiles
that had inhabited the world centuries
before had been able to evolve into the
dominant species while Humanity's
earliest ancestors had never climbed out
of the primordial soup
scp-507 found himself in a facility
overrun with reptilian researchers all
working for an organization called the
scaly carnivorous Predator Foundation
naturally the dinosaurs were fascinated
by the sudden and inexplicable existence
of this pink fleshy creature appearing
out of thin air although the researchers
working at this version of the
foundation were seemingly well versed in
the study of the anomalous unfortunately
there was something of a language
barrier between
scp-507 and the dinosaurs of this
Dimension a kind calm request for him to
come quietly so the research reptiles
could run tests ended up sounding like a
vicious bloodthirsty snarl and so The
Reluctant Dimension Hopper turned heel
and ran away from a flock of raptors in
Foundation lab coats until he eventually
displaced back to his original Dimension
again 1 30 p.m right sure they did 507.
Dalton sighed after her charge had
reappeared and recounted his story of
sentine dinosaurs running an alternate
version of the foundation and I bet Jeff
Goldblum and Laura Dern were both Public
Enemies in this universe too I wasn't
injured Jurassic Park
scp-507 argued his head splitting I
could have been eaten alive if those
Raptors had caught up to me officer
Dalton helped the blonde-haired and
greened-eyed dimension traveler to his
feet and began marching him towards a
debriefing room as part of their
continued Research into not only scp-507
but the wider Multiverse The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper often had to describe
his unplanned Expeditions after the fact
screw that I almost died he protested I
don't want to go and give a debrief I'll
do it later it's got to be past
lunchtime in this universe right he
asked you eat after debrief Dalton
insisted nah I want lunch
scp-507 retorted I need to recharge I'll
go sit with fernan reluctantly
remembering she'd been told to do
whatever the dimension Hopper asked
officer Dalton changed course and walked
him towards the enlarged containment
Area Housing
scp-082 Ferdinand was genetically an
ordinary human being being who had grown
into a giant through some unknown means
given that scp-507 was usually permitted
to freely interact with most other
relatively harmless anomalies he had
developed something of a friendship with
scp-082 as a result grab not considered
his visits to be a vacation of sorts
despite ferdinand's grotesque appearance
the giant was actually very friendly
especially towards scp-507 the
creature's body was dense with muscle
and fat heavily scarred and his face
disproportionate to the rest of him yet
both scp-082 and scp-507 seemed to
converse jovially and enjoyed each
other's company over lunch that is until
The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
unceremoniously displaced again Midway
through talking to his giant friend
about his latest multiversal Excursion
scp-082 turned to officer Dalton the
second grab knock had vanished and
Shrugged casually he does that 4pm over
the course of the next few hours at
least as the time passed in his home
Dimension
scp-507 was relocated into a universe
where everyone on Earth was a sentient
hot dog it was a jarring change to adapt
to although not quite as initially
frightening as encountering the
dinosaurs on his previous outing the hot
dog population were a bit more guarded
than the inhabitants of the last
Universe he'd been to but after ensuring
them that he meant no harm
scp-507 quickly established a rapport
with some of them the first question he
had was whether like the dinosaurs these
anthropomorphic baseball stand snags had
naturally evolved into the dominant
species over time
scp-507 was surprised to learn that in
actuality these hot dog creatures had
previously been human until a strange
plague had befallen them several hundred
thousand years prior ironically this had
all taken place before their
civilization had ever developed the
practice of eating sausages in bread
okay so let me follow that up with
another question
scp-507 declared make it quick man I'm
late for work the large talking hot dog
replied so when you all changed into hot
dogs did you really become sausages then
develop bread coats to wear or like are
you both wait what do you mean the hot
dog person replied you know because
technically a hot dog isn't a hot dog
until you put it in a bread roll
scp-507 explained so are you all
actually sausages or are you like
coalesced beings of both sausage and
bread the ensuing political unrest civil
turmoil and ethical outcry that overtook
the hot dog Dimension following
scp-507's question made him really glad
he displaced back home not long after he
couldn't help feel a little disheartened
too up until the hot dogs were trying to
place him over a giant Grill
scp-507 had actually found he'd been
enjoying the time he spent there still
he was grateful to be back in a universe
populated by actual humans once again
even if the first one he met Upon
returning officer Dalton was Furious
that he'd been gone for so long 7 PM you
know I'm wise to your act she replied
scp-507 had just requested dinner
although for some reason pointed out
that he wanted to avoid eating hot dogs
for a while what act he asked this thing
you do you're disappearing at the
officer responded you're not this
bumbling interdimensional traveler
you're just an immature brat five zero
seven you have to call me grab knock the
whoever or Tommy or guy or whatever the
hell your name is at this precise moment
in time Dalton snapped angrily forcing
scp-507 to go silent you just teleport
that's what you do you zip out of one
place and reappear in the next and give
Personnel like me the run around and
it's a hoot it's just a big joke you can
pull on all of us that would be bad
enough if you didn't come back with all
these absurd stories on top of it what's
next huh a dimension where the
foundation is run by cats or a world
where everyone is a sentient fart I
don't make it up
scp-507 replied meekly the place I end
up in are all real I I don't get to pick
where I displaced to or how weird it is
when I get there no I said that I
figured you out Dalton retorted you make
up some wild story these full Yarns you
keep spinning to confuse people then you
can request anything you want that's
your real anomalous trait grab knock the
Destroyer you're able to pull the wool
over our eyes and use it to Garner
special privileges a computer almost
total freedom to roam around the
foundation at will food and board
anything you want you get there was a
long awkward pause
scp-507 looked miserable he was aware
that as cruel as she was being officer
Dalton's anger was born more out of
frustration than anything else he
couldn't help his interdimensional
displacement disorder sure it had meant
the foundation offered him certain
treatments someone might consider to be
preferential but he was still trapped
not so much by the facility or even the
foundation themselves elves instead
scp-507 was trapped by his condition
unable to freely choose which Universe
he stayed in 8 PM Dalton had escorted
scp-5072 debrief then back to his
quarters the entire time an air of
uncomfortable silence followed them she
still wasn't entirely convinced that her
charges anomalous ability wasn't all a
sham at least in part but standing guard
at his bedroom door she could see him
soakly browsing the internet on his
computer he was quiet and Dalton
couldn't help that it did make her feel
a little bad for losing her temper at
him earlier hey um 507 she said poking
her head through the doorway he didn't
respond mindlessly scrolling without
turning around stepping inside Dalton
closed the gap between them by walking
towards scp-507 sat in his computer
chair listen scp-507 she repeated then
realizing why he wasn't replying or
paying her any notice with the roll of
her eyes and heavy exact aspirated Psy
officer Dalton readdressed The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper hey grab knock the
Destroyer hearing that made scp-507 turn
around in an instant giving her his full
attention ma'am he said still sulking
but at least willing to speak I'm very
sorry for what I said before Dalton
admitted I don't enjoy this you know
scp-507 said solemnly one minute I'm
somewhere familiar the next I'm thrust
into some horrible nightmare where
everyone's got macaroni and cheese for
hands or there's so many spiders
everywhere
it's not just a joke to me and it sucks
there were tears in the dimension
Hopper's eyes and officer Dalton reached
out to Pat him on the shoulder I know
and I'm sorry for saying you made it all
up she offered a smile then in a blink
of an eye they were both gone 10 pm
every other time that scp-507 had
displaced during the day the foundation
had barely painted any mind not even
reacting when officer Dalton had brought
it to their attention but the moment she
had disappeared along with The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper security staff and
researchers went into a frenzy alarms
sounded Personnel were patrolling the
corridors on mass sweeping room to room
with flashlights in the hopes not only
that scp-507 would return but officer
Dalton would still be with him when he
did it had been a few hours since the
pair of them had vanished the sun had
long since set and night had fallen yet
there was still no sign until a
researcher heard the sound of someone
sobbing coming from one of the storage
closets calling it in a trio of
foundation security cautiously
approached the closet and threw open the
door only to find scp-507 sat inside
weeping floods of Tears immediately
despite how late at night it was The
Reluctant Dimension Hopper was told he
needed to debrief on where he had just
been and what had happened to his
Handler officer Dalton
scp-507 began to describe displacing to
mentioned he had visited a number of
times before a reality that was shrouded
in complete darkness no sunlight at all
a familiar sound had instantly told The
Reluctant Dimension Hopper where he was
and that he wasn't alone doubly so
because officer Dalton's hand had been
on his shoulder completely by accident
she had transported there with him
switching on the flashlight he took with
him everywhere
scp-507 was horrifying to see a figure
who had tormented him before he wore a
black business suit the matching
sunglasses he had on made the figure
resemble a man and black agent it leered
at him and officer Dalton with an
unnaturally wide smile that had haunted
scp-507's nightmares ever since their
first encounter back again the figure
had said leaning in towards scp-507 and
this time you've brought a friend he
took her The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
said quietly as he sat in the debriefing
room The Smiling man got her we'd better
get you cleaned up and sent to bed 507
one of the researchers said forcing a
reassuring smile we'll assign you a new
Handler in the morning now go and check
out scp-507 reluctant Dimension Hopper
and can scp-096 chase its victims across
the Multiverse for more background on
the man who can travel the Multiverse
and quite literally can't stop